- [Charlie] I really
actually believe
your take on the
business of music.
The B2C and B2B--
- Correct.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
- What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
("Riot" by Jon Waltz)
- [Gary] Hey Dad, just calling
you to tell you I love you.
Hope you're having a
good day, hit me back.
Yeah. Yep.
Morning guys,
going up to North Jersey.
Heading to see a client.
It's been a hectic week ending
days at like 12, one o'clock.
Glad this week's over.
Get a little rest this weekend.
My nephew Max's
seventh birthday, laser tag.
Should be fun.
About to go on Instagram Live
to promote this "50 Seconds
To Every 50 Year Old."
I am on a mission for
every 50 year old in the world
to see this, so if you
got a 50 year old aunt,
uncle, brother, sister, child.
Please, please send it on.
Link it up here Babin.
Give me a little edit here.
Like give me something.
A little clip of it.
I mean crap, you could
play the whole damn thing.
It's only 50 seconds.
I need you to
understand something.
You have so much time.
I am flabbergasted
by how many people
think that at 50 it's over.
Avi, how old are you?
- [Avi] 44.
- 44.
Like, remember how old you
thought 44 was, 20 years ago.
- [Avi] (laughs) Yes.
- Like finished, right?
- [Avi] Correct.
- And doesn't it feel crazy
how young you feel right now?
- [Avi] I feel energized.
- Yeah, I feel like.
Well especially
now with this new job.
The energy's just
bolting in your fuckin' face.
24/7.
There's a fuckload
of 50-year-olds
that think their life is over.
That think it's over.
'Cause they've been playing
for 30 years professionally,
they're tired.
They've been an accountant
for 30 years, they hate it.
But they don't see any way out.
Because they don't realize
that there's Instagram Live.
'Cause they don't realize
that there's Facebook groups.
'Cause they don't
realize that they can do a blog.
realize they're a great writer.
And if they did 14 Medium
posts, they can blow up.
And so I'm on a mission
to get them to understand
that there's still 30,
40 years of amazing things.
Modern health,
these people are gonna be
healthy for another 30 years.
30.
You know how much shit you
can get done in 30 years Avi?
You were 14, 30 years ago Av?
- [Avi] That's correct.
- How old are you?
- [Other Tyler] 23.
- You were fuckin'
negative seven, mother fucker.
(group laughter)
This motherfucker
was negative seven.
I just, I want this one.
You know?
How old are your parents?
- [Other Tyler] 45.
- So, what the fuck?
Did you send it
to your parents yet?
- [Other Tyler] I will.
- No, give me the camera.
Let's do it right now.
Bam, you like that Avi?
That's the gangster
shit I do, you did it?
- [Other Tyler] Mom's got it.
- [Gary] Mom's got it.
Can't wait 'til she sees it.
India, I love you back.
You think mom's gonna be
mad at you that you said,
hey mom watch this, but it's
for 50 year olds and she's 45?
- [Other Tyler] Yeah, you
might've gotten me in trouble.
- Yeah
(laughing)
- I love it.
You know this 50
for 50 video I made?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Five seconds ago.
- The head of (censored) wants
me to give a keynote now.
How fucking cool is that?
Av, it's amazing how
like that works, right?
How are you?
- That meeting, on
the 31st that we had?
- Which one?
- James, Alex, Sophie.
Linda, Dan.
Content and theory would stem
from the direction we get out
of this meeting.
- Okay, all good,
all good stuff.
- [Woman 2] Okay. Cool.
(camera shutter clicking)
- Right then and there.
That they were completely lost
in the reality of the world.
I think the funniest part of
that statement is actually,
take the word music out
and put in any other word
and it's the same thing.
People are just
completely not quantifying
the communication
shifts of our society.
Can I give you a
great piece of advice?
Are you off the label now?
Put out as much
music as possible,
as often as possible.
And mix it between
covers and original.
The end.
And if you're good
enough, you will win.
Andy, how many
video interns do you want?
What do you say video, like.
- [Andy] 500.
No seriously, but
like chopping like editing?
- [Andy] Chopping, editing,
formatting for Facebook.
- Okay. Interns?
- [Andy] Interns.
- I'm gonna have them DM you.
- Okay.
- [Andy] Can I speak
with you because I--
- I want full time interns.
I want Babins.
If you're coming to intern,
you're not going back anywhere.
For at least a year.
Like why?
We lose all our value.
And the other thing is like,
no matter what,
I'm talking to you
'cause you're so recent.
No matter what the
person comes in with.
If you're good.
If you're good, I mean
you went through,
I mean, if you're good.
You come in, if you're like
I'm gonna do this for a year,
I'm gonna fuckin'
blow up my brand.
That's I mean,
what did you, actually,
fuckin' let's go right to it.
What did you
think was gonna happen?
- [Other Tyler] I mean, all
I ever do was like work
for you for a year, and
then go do my own thing.
- Right and now?
Same?
- [Other Tyler] But now I'm
gonna be here for a while.
- Yeah so like because
what happens is that,
that's amazing,
because that's exactly.
Were you just filming that?
- [Other Tyler] Yeah.
- Yeah, we need,
that is in the episode.
Because that's the punchline.
Dopey Phil, he interned too.
We are, we all understand
what's about to happen, right?
- How do you divide your time,
if you don't mind me asking?
How much is running this
and your other business
enterprises separately, your--
- GaryVee stuff?
- [Matthew] Inspirational,
motivational--
- I would say,
it is
90% VaynerMedia.
Why the inspirational,
motivational GaryVee
thing works,
is 'cause there's 11
people right there doing it.
- [Matthew] So little time
gets magnified like that.
- He's recording everything.
And so,
when there's a quote card,
when there's a
inspirational quote on Instagram
that's getting viral,
it was just something
I said in a meeting.
Especially when I hang
out with a character like you,
where we take
it to such a macro,
you might have a fuckin'
weeks worth of quote content.
Right, you know.
So you have some of that stuff.
- [Matthew] What do you mean?
- Those, now what
I do as an entrepreneur
'cause I don't have to do it
in a corporate environment,
is I actually see every
one of those things through.
When I, here's a good example.
Tyler, yesterday, when I was
like hey I've got an idea.
I make a video, 50
seconds for a 50 year old.
I make it,
I put money behind it.
And it's gone
completely batshit today.
- Limiting the
space between idea,
inspiration, and
creation and action.
- And then I do tons
of things that are bombs,
but it's easy and as long,
and the net
score's always positive,
and it's from a yes attitude.
If you have a no attitude,
you do none of them.
You know, like anyway,
so this is all of this.
Where am I going?
(background chatter)
Hey, this is actually perfect.
Meet my friend Matthew.
- [Matthew] I'm Matthew.
- Ben Soffer.
- [Matthew] Hi Ben.
- [Ben] Nice to meet you.
- I'm Mike.
- Hey Mike, Matthew.
- We're gonna
have a conversation.
(camera shutter clicking)
Every brand has what you have.
Everybody's got
somebody who's big,
who believes and then if
you can find the right combo
or connective tissue and
I appreciate the chance thing
because I haven't
been saying it that way,
that maybe the person not
only does the sponsored thing,
but is the executive
producer of something
that we're really
hacking for success,
but they have their say.
Creatively, you can have--
- All our (mumbles).
- 3rd and 4th, 5th space.
- Sure, essentially the--
- [Gary] What's it called?
- I've just been
finding whatever.
- No, no phone.
- No phone,
just do it in person?
- Tell him, tell
him no, I want it,
tell him I tried
to push Gary to it.
He said this is too
important and I hate--
- Got it, that
bullshit, yeah I get it.
- And then like,
call him real quick
and be like yo this is good.
When he really likes something,
when it's super important,
he doesn't even
wanna do phone, yeah.
(camera shutter clicking)
So, uh.
Just like that it's 3:41 P.M.,
it literally
feels like it's 9:30.
I don't know man,
being busy is amazing,
because you get
so much shit done.
Especially the way I do it,
fives and tens and fifteens,
maybe there's a good
chance, we should be doing
some new kind of editing.
So here's a good chance
for maybe all the B-roll
you caught up like
one second, it's like..
"Out Out" is doing
better than a TV Commercial,
I would actually really
like to talk to you about
possibly joining the board.
And straight up,
if you just wanna like
really fuck with the system.
- Which, six months
ago I was more protective.
- It would be amazing if
we could actually show that.
- [Other Tyler] Trying to think
of how I can edit it together.
- You can't, you can't.
You probably learned more about
business in the last hour,
than you've learned
in your whole life.
And that's the game.
If you wanna be an anomaly,
if you wanna be great,
you gotta do different things.
And so I think people
waste time all the time,
schedule all time,
just waste time.
Make decisions, do
it fast, get a lot done.
And this is
what people tell you,
when they get
context from my world.
I'm getting a weeks
worth of work in, in a day.
Which is why I'm
getting so much done.
And I think it's
because I understand that
most things don't matter.
And that if you
move fast, of course
certain plates
will hit the ground.
But, a lot of plates won't.
And it's a hell of a lot better
than thinking about
how your gonna keep
four plates up in the air.
And never doing it.
- [Charlie] The way
you beat everybody,
I think, is you only get data
if somehow gut was put
in to the atmosphere, right?
So then people can
make a decision on that.
Film, that song, that artist,
but someone has
to make a decision,
the artist's gut, the
executive, the talent manager,
the platform. Someone has
to put something out there,
for there to be data.
So the part of
gut for data to me,
is absolutely the most
interesting. That's why I would
say the next biggest talent,
is already out
there playing somewhere.
- [Gary] Talk to a girl today--
- It's the process
of finding that talent
and also making a bet on what
you see and what you feel.
- And what people
have been doing
that look like you and I,
is they curtail themselves.
Drake would have two
albums right now if it was 1984.
Maybe three.
- Your right.
- [Gary] I know. I don't know
anything about
the music business.
But that part I know.
And you know,
fucking Russ, in Atlanta
is only famous 'cause he
puts out a song every week.
- Right.
- More is more man.
- Mikey actually said that
you need to be the chairman.
- And that person's right.
- [Charlie] More is more.
- More is more.
Ready? If you're good
enough? I'm good enough!
- [Charlie] How about this,
we put out an album,
it gets old by a week.
Isn't that interesting?
If you put an album
out of 10 or 12 songs,
what the streaming
guys were telling us,
is the album
becomes old very quick.
What does that mean?
Feed the beast, more is more.
- [Gary] More is more.
- [Charlie] You made a
hit yesterday right?
- Yes. Today.
- [Charlie] How many
times do you put hits out
and how many times did you
hit singles and doubles, right?
- Correct.
- Right so, from a
competitive point of view
you wanna always put,
I always say good
is the evil of great.
- If Drake put
out 365 days of songs
for the rest of his life, he
would win. If he's capable.
- [Charlie] Is good
the evil of great?
- No. Good is
the gateway to great.
(laughing)
- You guys gotta follow me,
you guys gotta follow me here.
I want you to look at my shit.
Gary V.
- You remember me from LA right?
- [Charlie] Yeah, man. Charlie.
- From the Ritz, this is
the president of Republic.
- [Charlie] Hi, Charlie.
- Oh it's nice to meet you.
- GaryVee!
I gotta get a picture.
- [Gary] Let's do it man.
- There's no way.
I got GaryVee--
- I'm here.
- and the president of
freaking Republic right here.
You kidding me.
- [Charlie] My brother.
- [Gary] Good guy.
- [Julian] What kind
of day is this?
- [Gary] What's your name?
- Julian Bow.
I'm a huge fan, I got
all three of your books.
- Thank you so
much, brother. Thank you.
- Nice to meet you man.
- [Julian] He's gonna
own the Jets one day!
- That's true! That's true!
Remember when hip hop
artists wanted to be athletes?
And athletes wanted
to be hip hop artists?
- They say rock
starts wanna be musicians
and musicians wanna
be rock starts, yeah.
- Right. They both
wanna be entrepreneurs.
- Now they wanna
be entrepreneurs?
- And there's only
one entrepreneur for them.
(clicks tongue)
And that's why you
just saw what you just saw.
If you were confused.
- Shit's about to go down.
(Gary laughs)
("Riot" by Jon Waltz)
I'm feeling really
good about what's going on.
And you see it right,
you see the chirping, right?
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing, Tyler.
Just is man.
I was so pumped you
were in that meeting Linds.
- [Lindsay] I know.
- You know 'cause
I love you so much
and I know a lot about you.
And I know a lot about like,
I just I know a lot about you.
And I love that that meeting,
you're there just because
that's the action and the
game and the heights
that you wanna be playing at.
And so it makes the
(censored) meeting palpable in
the clouds and dirt world.
We have to have those
meetings to make all the
other shit
palpable in the short term.
(camera shutter clicking)
Yeah!
(laughing)
- [Man] So what we did was,
we have a ritual in the office,
started seven years back
when we started this company.
9:30 in the morning
they have a 15 minute ritual,
2:30 in the afternoon
they have a 15 minute ritual.
We start with some
kind of chanting and praying
and everybody
embraces the energy.
You know they don't think of
the negative stuff as much.
Then there's a
motivational video from GaryVee
and in the afternoon.
- [Gary] Wow, I'm very flattered.
- [Man] So I'm thinking
does Gary even know that?
I think he's
counting it as one view.
And there's 120 of
us watching two videos,
every single day for the last,
you know how every many years
that you've putting out on,
every single day.
We can not be missed
by one person in the office.
So these are the three
trajectories that happen.
(video playing on phone)
- What up Internet Moguls?
It's me GaryVee.
You may know that, I think
you see me a whole bunch,
because of this dude!
Had a great meeting,
I just wanna send my love.
Thank you so much for the
love that you gave me first,
and I can't wait to
actually meet you guys.
- [Man] Thanks, Gary.
("Riot" by Jon Waltz)
- Good to see you. All well?
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- [ASAP] Hey,
how are you doing buddy?
- It's a real pleasure,
my man, how are you?
It's all good man!
- I appreciate it.
- What's up man?
- [Man 3] How are you, sir?
- How are you?
- [Man 3] Good!
- [Gary] It's so funny right,
when people meet people,
everybody thinks you are,
like America loves
to put you in one part.
- [ASAP] Yeah, being a
rapper is one part of me,
and I went to
college for marketing so.
- I totally get it.
Same thing with my crossover,
when I started
dropping references like
"Oh, you love hip hop?"
I'm like, "Why wouldn't I?"
That's just America,
America's obsessed with like,
you're a basketball
player, you're a painter,
you're an entrepreneur.
- [ASAP] This is music to my
ear, this is just letting me know
everything I'm
thinking is right.
- [Gary] It's more
right than you think.
(group laughter)
It's more right than you think.
It's don't hedge anymore.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Forget everything
you grew up with and
you think is real.
- [ASAP] Yeah.
- And turn it from color to
black and white, start over
and go with that gut.
- [ASAP] What's going on
in your head right now?
Are you who you wanted
to be? In your head, already?
- [Gary] I always knew
I was gonna be the biggest.
- That's what
I'm saying so you are
who you wanted
to be in your head?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- That's crazy 'cause I
didn't think it would stop,
so good, it's a point
where you get to stop.
- [Gary] No no! No no!
- No no I'm not
talking about stop working,
what I'm saying--
- [Gary] No no, no no,
you're already there too.
- [ASAP] No.
- No, you are let
me explain what I mean
- [ASAP] Alright.
- It is and it isn't.
"I'm the best and
I don't mean shit."
"I did it and
I haven't even started."
Once you learn how to pull
from both sides, you're set.
Let's get to know each other.
- [ASAP] Yeah, I can't wait.
("Riot" by Jon Waltz)
- It's very close.
It's very close.
This? I fucking,
I'll fit it easy.
- [Man 4] Ah, from
the same guy. Full zip.
- Holy shit! I'm fucking
wearing this shit all the time!
(group laughter)
Holy shit.
I might change.
Holy, of course.
I'm 100%!
- This guy sent you
like an amazing package.
- You know what?
When you decide
somebody did it real proper?
Come in with your
phone, tell me who it is,
I'll make a video
and give 'em real love
and we gotta send it back.
- Alright, we'll do that.
- Yeah. Holy shit!
This is so swagged out.
It's the compound
of the momentum.
By the way, what about
when I have my one video
or one moment
off the big famous,
I was zero and made videos
that would get a lot of things,
when you got base like this,
what I know that I'm
gonna do, is not change.
You evolve but I'm
pumping out content,
like I don't give a
fuck what's going on
and I'm gonna say something
and that video's
gonna get 47 million views.
- [Emily] See how you just
react to the market and wait
and like you counter puncture?
- Yeah
- [Emily] Yeah, I think I'm
going on the offense in 2017.
This is what's
happening this month,
we're doing it
and then doing it.
So, yeah, I'm making progress.
- [Gary] I think I'm
gonna do the call-in show.
- [Emily] Oh yeah?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Emily] Now is a good time.
- I think I am.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk.
And this is episode 239
of the The #AskGaryVee Show!
- [Andy] Dude, we
haven't even started yet.
Bringing these people on.
I've talked to a
couple of hip hop dudes
and they all just DM'd you.
Yesterday they were like,
"Yo, what's going on with Saba?"
"Why are they
meeting with Gary?"
"Does he listen to my music?"
(group laughter)
- Let's get outta here.
("Riot" by Jon Waltz)